good morning John I'm currently in
Florida visiting my in-laws and I wanted
to introduce you to the newest member of
this little family this is Horacio he's
my news it uh he's pretty nice guy he's
actually a bit of a jerk he say I had
everybody a ratio 99.99% of people right
now are thinking like yeah yeah but
there is that point zero one percent of
people who who are named Horatio who are
just mad at me right now sorry her
ratios and also everybody else didn't
tell me what stage and an adult man's
life he stops getting gigantic zits
because I waiting for that day for a
long time
it would be really nice other than that
my life is doing quite well I was just
visiting friends in Orlando and
remembering how great high school times
were I hope that people uh anyone
someone in the world somewhere had as
much fun with their friends in high
school as I did have to say to those
people thank you for making me a more
fun and better person silliness is a
vastly underappreciated quality in
humanity I don't know why it is not
among our major virtues diligence and
kindness and patience and humility and
silliness oh yeah I have a message from
Hank from the past Hank from the past
kick it hello which is me from the past
you can tell because of all the hair I'm
just here to tell you that this is five
hundred and twelve dollars that
nerdfighters gave to me for my birthday
and I'm taking to the bank deposit it so
that I can donate it to an organization
of my choosing which you will find out
shortly also I'm hoping they'll take the
Canadian money in the euros dupe did you
write to the bank the bank to the bank
now I'm going to go get my haircut
I know messing with time today so yeah I
got a haircut what do you think it's a
little messy now I guess Messi's in
though my dreams of looking like Topher
from dollhouse every day for the rest of
my life have been squashed but I'm
dealing with it you know every day is a
struggle so after I deposit of that
money and also did all the calculations
to figure out how much the foreign money
was worth I came to the conclusion that
I had six hundred and thirty four
dollars and twelve cents that
nerdfighters had given me for my
birthday to donate to a charity of my
car a charity of my cause of course
cause of my choosing charity of my host
of Bunge mums but I cannot help but
donate it to to water.org who I went to
Haiti with to learn how they operate and
what they do and because I'm such a fan
the work that water.org does and also
because I'm inspired by the charity of
nerdfighteria I've decided to double the
amount that you gave me and I'm now
giving that money to water.org thank you
speaking of which if you go to my water
org slash blog brothers you can see how
Sivan taboc the community that I visited
is doing a path to getting a well they
have formed the well committee they have
created a budget for the well they have
chosen a location and a guard for the
well I encourage you once again to go
and follow uh Sivan to balk at my water
organ also to donate money directly to
them you don't have to send it to me
first I'm just gonna give it to
water.org anyway just on this uh in the
corner don't know what's up with him is
this copyright is this copyright
violation Disney owns him go away Winnie
go away you could get me sued don't miss
you wouldn't appear this one isn't
copyrighted uh because it's so scary oh
man
you too I've just discovered a cache of
amazingly disfigured and frightening
antique toys so I'm gonna go away
because I'm scared for my life
so Horatio wanted you all to know that
he's doing his best to get rid of this
face so it can just be him doing the
vlogs but you know you guys can vote
which one you think would be better at
this job not you okay no so y'all see
you on Wednesday